Jimmy thank from gamespot here speaking
with erasers Chris and Chris what are we
looking at here today htk to this is the
latest version of hours via hecka
development kit and this is the first
half way that's actually on par with the
rift and the Vice so we upgrade the
display educator because it's the dual
display solution so we got 1080 x 1200 /
I and it's a 90 frames per second
display so essentially we're now looking
at like a display that is on par with
anything out there when you guys first
revealed the hacker development kit you
know virtual reality headset you guys
were pitching it's like it was something
geared for the hackers or you know
developers and things like that but now
you guys are sort of transitioning into
a full-fledged on consumer device is
that accurate to say or I think there's
like so VI as a whole still has has ways
to go in terms of being fully consumer
ready i would consider this an
enthusiast product i suppose to get to
this full easy out-of-the-box experience
vr as a whole like regardless of which
the absolution go with isn't quite there
yet but for enthusiasts that
enthusiastic about via this is perfectly
viable not just hackers like oral or
develop a second users and so if I if I
borrow this thing and you know I play
video games on it where will I be able
to go is gonna have steam spores can
have the oculus rift store support how
does that work yes I can it's no I mean
we want to get as much content as
possible as supported so to that extent
we just announced a five-million-dollar
def fund as well that we fund content
developers game develops in particular
to bring their game stores yeah we've
exclusive or as ibin teams also what
we're doing with us via is no
restriction so you can make it work with
anything else and the other hardware
with any other stores whatever it is
zero restrictions so that's the whole
point we want to enable content
developers to go to as many platforms as
well in fact it's encouraged to also be
an oculus at all to the unseen
on all platforms as much as possible
just to help them basically be more
financially stable when developing for
someone unknown market so a small target
market and yes we have latest support
for cry and unreal we have plugins
support for for unity and through the
deaf deaf found we're bringing most part
and we have promised about on Steam do
as well so all games that a developer
cvr do work on any or three and able
device including hbk to as well how you
guys handling tracking I know you know
you guys have said you guys gonna sports
team we have a camera somewhere here
which I don't know where but they
infrared LEDs in there they allow proper
currently primarily for seafood
experience but the solution is scalable
to room scale experience in the future
so you won't as of right now you won't
be able to use the lighthouse on it bubs
so lighthouse it would be a different
technology I mean generally lattice with
in OC are supported so you can you can
get tracking from a lighthouse to us via
but it would wouldn't really make sense
to combine two different tracking
solutions one the inside out one outside
in in that sense so with HEK you would
be using an infrared camera similar more
similar to the rift I'm for a tracking
solution I guess I'm still on my big
concern is if I want to play steam VR
games and it does and you have to use
room scale and this doesn't quite
support room so how does that as I work
okay no um today you probably wouldn't
use this for any room scale experiences
in the near future fear we will be
enabling that with a second camera our
team is working on it's not ready yet so
wherever really were talking about it
but the solution itself is scalable so
today if you want to get room scale
experiences this wouldn't be the
solution you will go for further down
the line it's fun certainly possible so
today it's mostly the experiences that
have been developed for Cindy I'm not
necessary for room scale or the ones
that support both room scale and seated
experiences and then I you know cost
four hundred dollars that right yes
foreign at aulis or you reprise should
be 500 I think
and available first of july four i think
first week of july for pre owners and
does it come with any controller or
anything like that or control it so we
give people like we don't bundle
anything because again depending on what
content you want to play with you may
need a motion or you may need a gamepad
you may be mouse and keyboard so we
don't bundle anything in cool thank you
Chris for more III coverage stay tuned
to gamespot com